in this video we're going to talk about
enzymes and in particular we're going to
talk about the effect of ph
on enzymes how acidic or basic the
environment is how that affects enzyme
activity
so just as a bit of review enzymes are
molecules that help catalyze various
reactions and they are all throughout
biological systems most enzymes are
proteins large proteins often times made
up of chains of amino acids
and so i could draw a chain of amino
acid where each of these circles
represents an amino acid and the primary
structure is just a sequence of the
amino acids but there's also a secondary
structure on how this amino acid
backbone interacts with itself and a lot
of that is based on hydrogen bonding so
that amino acid and that amino acid
maybe it forms some type of hydrogen
bond and just as a review a hydrogen
bond is an interaction between
hydrogen and a more electronegative atom
so for example we've seen this in water
let me draw a couple of
water molecules
right over here
and this is all review in water you have
these covalent bonds between the oxygen
and the hydrogen so arguably they're
sharing the electrons but because oxygen
is more electronegative it likes to hog
the electrons more the electrons spend
more time around the oxygens so the
oxygen end of a water molecule gets a
partially negative charge and then the
hydrogen ends of a water molecule get a
partially positive
partially positive charge this is the
greek
lowercase delta for partially
partial charge is what it's typically
used for and so the partially negative
ends would be attracted to the partially
positive ends of another molecule and
that's what hydrogen bonds are it's not
always between hydrogen oxygen in fact
oftentimes it's between hydrogen and
nitrogen which is another
electronegative atom
and these hydrogen bonds not only do
they help to find the secondary
structure of the proteins which helps to
find the shape of the protein they can
also interact with the substrate of the
protein the things that the proteins
trying to catalyze reactions on so for
example if that's the substrate and i'm
just doing it as a big red circle parts
of it might form hydrogen bonds with the
enzyme itself and if you want to see a
more complex picture of that
this is a detailed schematic of a
substrate interacting with an enzyme
where what you see in circled in yellow
that is the substrate here and you see
these dotted lines those are the
hydrogen bonds so you can see a hydrogen
bond between a hydrogen and a nitrogen a
hydrogen bond between an oxygen and a
hydrogen and so the yellow part is a
substrate and all the stuff that's
wrapping around it that is the enzyme
itself
so that out of the way how does ph play
into it well we just have to remind
ourselves what ph is
ph which is often viewed as the power of
hydrogen that's where the p comes from
is the negative log or at least the way
it's introduced in many introductory
chemistry class the negative log of the
hydrogen
ion concentration and a hydrogen ion is
essentially a proton
well how would this affect an enzyme's
shape and its ability to interact with
the substrate the thing that it's trying
to act on
well if you have a bunch of depending on
how many hydrogen ions you have floating
around and oftentimes it'll be in the
form of hydronium which is a water
molecule where the oxygen is bonded to
one extra hydrogen proton
well it might mess with these hydrogen
bonds where some of these hydrogen
protons usurp the bond with the negative
end of one of these molecules or repel
some of the positive ends of some of
these molecules in a certain way and so
you can imagine that different enzymes
might have a different level of activity
at different levels of ph and that
actually is the case in fact you will
often see a diagram that looks like this
so in the vertical axis you will often
see
reaction
velocity
where reaction velocity goes higher as
we go higher in the vertical direction
and
in this axis right over here
you might see
our level
of ph
and remember ph because you have this
negative out front
a high
hydrogen ion concentration
because of this negative
that will give you a low
ph and that is associated with acidic
acidic environments and a low hydrogen
ion concentration that's associated with
a high
ph once again because of this negative
out front and that's associated with a
more basic
situation and if your ph is around seven
then that would be a neutral situation
but different enzymes activities peak at
different phs so for example you might
have an enzyme like this whose activity
peaks at a ph of
let's say this is right over here a ph
of four which is relatively acidic and
you would typically see this type of an
enzyme in say a place like the stomach
which is a very acidic environment and
then you might see other enzymes that
actually don't do too well in an acidic
environment but do quite well in a more
neutral environment
so for example this peak
might be at say a ph of 7. and then you
might have other enzymes that do better
in a basic environment and we actually
do see this in the human body for
example lipase which is an enzyme that
breaks down fat
when it's found in the stomach that
particular version of lipase it actually
has optimum activity closer to this at a
ph of roughly four or five while lipase
that is secreted from the pancreas which
acts in the small intestines which is a
more neutral environment or even
slightly basic its optimal activity is
at a ph of 8.
so i will leave you there big picture is
is that a lot of an enzyme's shape or
its ability to interact with the
substrate is based on hydrogen bonds and
so you can imagine hydrogen bonds could
be influenced by hydrogen ion
concentration and so because of that
depending on your enzyme and sometimes
the substrate that you're dealing with
you might have different reaction
velocities at different phs with some
enzymes doing better in acidic
environments and other enzymes doing
better in neutral or basic environments